how did you get the job on idiot tests
how did that all transpire
um i've done a couple things with game
show network over the years and they've
been looking for a show for me to host
and they told me they were trying to
find one and i didn't really believe it
you know you
always hear people in hollywood saying
that oh i want to find a show for you
and then
they actually did they just asked me to
host a run-through in a conference room
of india tests and i met before we did
that with the producers and learned the
game
and it was a really good fit for my
comedy and for what i like to do and for
my sensibility and it's a really smart
show and i enjoyed that aspect of it and
the conference room run through went
great i lived here in l.a but i was in
new york on vacation i flew back just
for 12 hours just to do the run through
and flew back to my vacation and
and it went amazingly they picked up 40
episodes for season one right from that
run through they didn't even have to
pilot after that so
it went pretty well and now we're doing
season two so it's exciting 65 more
episodes okay thanks
so wait i'm sorry did i miss how did you
initially get that like how did you know
that connection
did you did you already audition for
something else forgive me no just game
show network had just
had me i guess they you know became fans
of some of the things i'd done
over the years and they had me come in
over the years and and host different
pilots for them and
appear as a guest on some of their shows
so the relationship started that way
and they just always you know kept me in
mind which i appreciated because it
worked out in me getting a show
on their network that's a hit so that's
fun so i know
when that 12-hour like flying there and
and i i heard you quickly save you as we
were setting up that you love pressure
and that you thrive on it
how was that like you're flying it was
great yeah i
i flew you know around the country on
the red eye
left new york i think it was at 6 00 a.m
and returned at 6 a.m the next day
i was in l.a only for 12 hours and i was
on no sleep and i had to do that
audition
and then go after i booked that there
was another audition for a fox show
called weird loners for scripted acting
role
that i auditioned for and then i had to
learn both those and then fly right back
and both went really well and i felt
great and i did not get the scripted
fox show it's gonna be coming out on tv
anyway though despite the fact they made
the mistake of not casting me
so that's on them you know as far as
life
errors sure and they have to accept it
they have to live with that you know
that's just how they're going to have to
move on now but i got idiot test and uh
yeah i love pressure to me i can be very
lazy
if i don't have a lot going on but when
i
take on projects and when i decide to do
things i
i want 10 things at my shoulders at once
for some reason i just like a deadline
like a hammer being over my head
figuratively
i don't want a hammer on top of my head
in life
not a real hammer
you